El 11 de abril de 2015 se produjo una histórica reunión entre Raúl Castro, el presidente
de Cuba y Barack Obama.
Se celebró en Panamá y fue el primer encuentro
bilateral entre los Presidentes de Estados
Unidos y Cuba en más de 50 años.
Apenas 4 meses antes, ambos mandatarios habían
anunciado que iban a retomar las relaciones
entre ambos gobiernos.
Y dicho y hecho.
Pronto empezaron a sucederse los cambios para
lograr que las relaciones entre ambos países
fuesen normales.
Sin embargo, una vez más, la llegada de Donald
Trump al despacho oval lo ha cambiado… todo.
El nuevo presidente de los Estados Unidos
ha ordenado dar marcha atrás y acabar
con muchos de los cambios que Obama había puesto sobre la mesa respecto a Cuba
¿Por qué lo hace?
¿Qué espera conseguir?
¿Qué consecuencias va a tener su nueva política?
Vamos a verlo, pero antes vamos a mirar un poco hacia atrás en el tiempo.
Tras culminarse la llamada “Revolución
Cubana” contra la dictadura de Batista,
el nuevo gobierno de la isla, dirigido
por Fidel Castro, comenzó muy pronto a nacionalizar
todo tipo de activos y de empresas: tierras,
hoteles, fábricas… todo.
Fijaos, si la revolución cubana culminó
el 1 de enero de 1959, en mayo el gobierno
de la isla ya había comenzado la expropiación
masiva de propiedades.
Algo que por supuesto, como os podéis imaginar,
no sentó nada bien en Estados Unidos donde
las reclamaciones se contaban por miles; y
es que por aquel entonces las relaciones
entre ambos países eran muy estrechas.
Y por si fuese poco, la Unión Soviética
andaba ya haciendo buenas migas con Fidel Castro.
(Pues bien, en Washington respondieron a las
expropiaciones aprobando un primer embargo
comercial contra la isla, un embargo que poco
a poco -a medida que las relaciones se deterioraban-
iba haciéndose más fuerte.)
De hecho, tras la crisis de los misiles de
1962, Kennedy restringió incluso los viajes
de estadounidenses a la isla.
Desde entonces, amigos, y salvo un corto periodo
de deshielo bajo las administraciones de Ford
y Carter, los diferentes gobiernos de Estados
Unidos han mantenido el embargo y su empeño
de aislar económicamente a Cuba.
(Ronald Reagan calificó a la isla como patrocinador
del terrorismo, Bill Clinton endureció aún
más las restricciones y bajo su mandato el
embargo se convirtió en ley.
Desde entonces viajar a Cuba, invertir allí o tener negocios con el gobierno cubano
ha sido muy restringido para los estadounidenses.)
Pues bien, así es, está ha sido la pauta
habitual, hasta que llegó Barack Obama.
(Durante las elecciones de 2008, y coincidiendo además con que en febrero de ese mismo año
Fidel Castro le había cedido el poder a sus
hermano Raul, Obama dijo que había
llegado la hora de emplear un enfoque diferente con Cuba y el momento de recuperar las relaciones
diplomáticas entre ambos países.)
Dicho y hecho, Obama no se hizo esperar y
al poco de llegar a la Casa Blanca, en el
plazo de apenas unas semanas, como primer
gesto de una nueva política alivió algunas
restricciones que pesaban sobre Cuba:
por ejemplo, permitió que los cubanos en
Estados Unidos enviasen remesas ilimitadas
a la isla y también empezó a abrir la mano
permitiendo que los ciudadanos de estados
unidos empezaran a poder viajar a Cuba.
Ojo, primer paso al que sucedieron otros muchos.
Durante la etapa de Obama poco a poco se fueron
moderando muchas de las restricciones que
pesaban sobre Cuba.
En 2014 ambos países anunciaron el restablecimiento
de los lazos diplomáticos.
Los gestos continuaban.
(Y así llegaron los dos grandes momentos,
en 2015 las embajadas se reabrieron y finalmente
en marzo de 2016 el Air Force One aterrizaba
por primera vez en la historia en La Habana.
Y es que Cuba no recibía la visita de un
presidente estadounidense en ejercicio desde
1928.)
La nueva política de Obama hacia Cuba avanzó
con paso decidido y…. aunque las leyes del
embargo continuaban en vigor, su administración
se las ingenió para buscar recovecos legales
que de facto permitieran que las relaciones
entre ambos países fuesen… normales.
Cuando Obama dejó la Casa Blanca, los estadounidenses ya podían viajar a Cuba libremente,
los inmigrantes podían enviar remesas ilimitadas, las empresas estadounidenses podían invertir en Cuba,
e incluso  los aviones de las compañías estadounidenses aterrizaban frecuentemente en el
Aeropuerto Internacional José Martí, el aeropuerto
de la Habana…
vamos que la cosa marchaba.
Pero en estas, Donald Trump se convirtió
en el nuevo Presidente de Estados Unidos…Y
todo cambió.
El pasado 16 de junio de 2017 Trump decidió dar
marcha atrás a toda la política de apertura
hacia Cuba.
Lo hizo en el barrio de Miami conocido como
Little Havana:
Nada más terminar el discurso Trump firmó
una directiva para aplicar lo que él mismo
ha denominado su “nueva política”, aunque,
la verdad, después de más de 50 años de
embargo de nueva política no tiene nada.
(La marcha atrás de Trump no será completa,
se mantendrán muchas de las medidas tomadas
por Obama como la apertura de las embajadas
o los vuelos comerciales entre ambos países.)
(Sin embargo, a partir de ahora se restringen
los viajes de los estadounidenses a Cuba,
que ya no lo podrán hacer a título individual
y se prohíbe cualquier relación con GAESA,
un holding de empresas dirigido por el ejército
que controla más del 50% de la economía
cubana.)
Ojo no os penséis que Trump siempre ha defendido
la mano dura contra Cuba… Para nada.
En 1998 trató de construir un hotel en la
isla violando el embargo, a principios de
2016 apoyó la apertura de Obama y luego,
pues bueno… Lo que toca ahora es, al parecer,
mano dura…
Claro que…. esto es un error ¿Por qué?
Veámoslo.
Digámoslo claro, el embargo ha sido un rotundo
fracaso.
Durante más de 50 años el embargo ha sido
totalmente inútil, no ha conseguido ningún
objetivo y encima ha sido la mejor excusa
del gobierno cubano para justificar sus pésimos
resultados.
Pero, esperad un momento, porque aquí no
termina todo ni de lejos.
Dar marcha atrás a la política Obama es
un error por muchos motivos:
Por un lado, la normalización de las relaciones
con Cuba ha mejorado la seguridad de los propios
Estados Unidos. Tal como lo escucháis.
Obama firmó numerosos convenios de colaboración
y por ejemplo, desde 2015 las autoridades
cubanas han entregado información sobre narcotráfico
o trata de personas.
(Por otro lado, Rusia y China han vuelto a
poner sus ojos en la Isla.
De hecho, Moscú ha llegado a decir que se
está planteando negociar con La Habana la
reapertura de bases militares en Cuba, lo
que supondría una verdadera bofetada a la
estrategia de seguridad nacional de Estados
Unidos.)
Es decir, tensar hoy las relaciones y endurecer
el embargo, no supone más que obligar al
gobierno de Cuba a echarse, otra vez, en brazos
de Moscú o Pekín.
Menudo Negocio.
Y aún hay más, amigos, la nueva política
de Trump no solo puede dañar los intereses
de muchas empresas de Estados Unidos, sino
que también pone en riesgo los cambios que
se están empezando a producir en la isla,
porque amigos, Cuba está cambiando.
Desde que Raúl Castro llegó al poder, el
gobierno de Cuba ha reconocido que tiene que
cambiar el rumbo, que el modelo cubano simplemente
no funciona.
Según dicen quieren hacer lo que hizo China:
abrirse al mundo manteniendo el control.
Lo cierto es que hasta ahora los cambios han
sido muy lentos y muy escasos… pero aún
así ya se están notando y ahora que Venezuela
ya no puede ayudar a la isla la urgencia de
estos cambios es aún mayor.
(Desde que en 2011 se introdujeron reformas
y se facilitaron los negocios por cuenta propia,
el número de trabajadores autónomos en Cuba
se ha multiplicado por cuatro y hoy ya supera
el medio millón; el gobierno también ha
comenzado a permitir la producción agrícola
privada para los pequeños campesinos e incluso
los restaurantes y pequeños negocios
privados enfocados al turismo están creciendo
como la espuma.)
La apertura de Obama ha ayudado mucho en todo
este proceso.
Casi todos los negocios privados en Cuba se
montan con el dinero que llega de las remesas
y por ejemplo AirBNB tiene ya en Cuba 22.000
apartamentos, casas o habitaciones entre sus
ofertas.
Y además, no debemos olvidar que el intercambio
de ideas, el conocimiento de lo que ocurre
en el exterior y el fortalecimiento del sector
privado es la mejor forma de lograr cambios
políticos.
(Cuando un estadounidense visita la isla,
y ojo, cada vez son más, con cada conversación
y con cada dólar que gastan en taxis particulares,
pequeños restaurantes o habitaciones favorecen
no solo la mejora de vida de los cubanos,
sino que también mejoran su capacidad para
ser libres.)
Fijaos sino en China y comparad la China de
hoy con la China de Mao.
Desde que este país se abrió al mundo cientos
de millones de chinos han dejado atrás la
pobreza y encima con su producción han permitido
que muchos otros millones de personas en el
resto del mundo hayan mejorado su nivel de
vida.
China, como Cuba, sigue siendo una horrible
dictadura, pero gracias a la apertura los
chinos hoy tienen más libertad al tiempo
que ha mejorado su nivel de vida.
La política del embargo ha fracasado y el
empeño de Trump por volver atrás no va a
lograr nada más que debilitar la seguridad
de estados unidos, empobrecer al pueblo cubano
y frenar los cambios en la isla.
En febrero de 2018 Raul Castro dejará el
poder, no es el momento de dar marcha atrás.
“Además, en 2013 el gobierno cubano suprimió
las visas de salida.
Hoy no es extraño que miembros de la sociedad
civil como empresarios, académicos o disidentes
políticos salgan y regresen al país.
Esto es un gran paso porque facilita la cooperación
con empresas, sociedades y organismos internacionales”:
Trump se justifica -según él dice- en querer
defender los derechos humanos, eso está bien,
pero ¿no os parece un tanto  hipócrita defender el embargo en Cuba
y al mismo tiempo abrazarse con los dirigentes
de Arabia Saudita. ¿Dónde quedan ahí los derechos humanos?
Y, ojo, por todo esto 10 senadores republicanos
han criticado ya el cambio de rumbo respecto
a Cuba.
Pero ahora te toca el turno a ti, puedes dejarnos
tu opinión en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta ¿Debe Donald Trump dar marcha
atrás a la política de Obama respecto a
Cuba?
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like, y
ya sabes si quieres seguir todas nuestras
novedades no te olvides de suscribirte al
canal y seguirnos también en Facebook y Twitter.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.